n étant ni père croissance après avoir
multiplié son chiffre d'affaires par
quatre entre 2019 et 2020 r captifs
vient d'être racheté par le groupe
michelin spécialisée dans la production
de structures gonflables cette start-up
devient une filiale à 100 % du géant du
pneumatique durant la crise qu vide en
fait les deux sociétés avaient commencé
à travailler ensemble en fait sur une
thématique de coussins gonflables à
usages médicaux lorsqu'emmanuel fievet
le fondateur de deir captifs c'est s'est
manifestée commettre comme étant
vendeurs de sa société de sa start up et
les pourparlers se sont engagés durant
l'année 2000 21 engagés dans les
secteurs de l'aéronautique de la défense
du nucléaire ou du médical r captifs va
pouvoir bénéficier des capacités de
l'expérience de michelin objectif
structurer l'hypercroissance de cette
start-up d'une trentaine de salariés ça
va nous apporter plus de moyens humains
et financiers on a déjà vu pas mal de
personnes arrivées pour nous aider à
s'agrandir et puis à faire plus de
chiffre d'affaires et puis à gérer plus
facilement les les problèmes du
quotidien michelin a créé la société
with hameau qui était qui sont des
voiles dévoile gonflables et où
finalement michelin n'a peut-être pas
forcément l'expérience dans ce domaine
là d'un domaine du gonflage à basse
pression à porter ça avec près de deux
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
réalisés en 2021 air captive souhaite
doubler ce résultat en 2022 et devenir à
terme le leader européen des structures
gonflables